(upbeat hip hop music)
(laughing)
(seagulls cawing)
♪ The weather cold ♪
♪ The weather's so chill chilly willy ♪
♪ Penguin feather robe ♪
♪ Are they acting up ♪
♪ Get your weapons on ♪
♪ You're only killin' time ♪
- Who the fuck?
- Hey!
Sully, how can I help you, fam?
You're looking mad stressed.
- What are you going to do?
- Stand up.
- What are you going to do, huh?
- Don't fucking touch me.
- 'Cause you're getting out on Friday,
you're gonna come here and just
have a conversation, I'm disappointed.
- Get your fucking guys
out my cell, blood.
- Oooh, Sully, summerhouse Sully.
You ain't going no where on Friday.
Fucking pussy.
- Oy!
(agonizing screams)
- Shh, who's the fucking pussy now?
(whistle blowing)
- [Guard] Everybody in your cells, move!
Move move move, get in
your cells, now gentleman!
(whistle)
- Jason.
- Yeah.
- Come on man, you good?
- Yeah, man, I'm good, how are you?
- I'm all right.
- Good, good, man.
- Looking big.
- Look at yourself, man.
- If you could do
anything out of anything,
what would it be?
- I want super powers,
just like Spider Man.
- Yo, man, not superpowers.
Like, in the real world.
Like something you could really have.
- Know what?
To go watch Arsenal play
'cause they're the best fucking team
in the whole Premier League.
- (laughs) to come watch Arsenal?
- Yeah!
- All right, it's done.
- No.
- Yeah!
- Great, thank you!
- When we get back to the inn I'll
Take you to watch Arsenal.
- Yes!
Fuckin' kick some arse, mate.
(fire blazing)
(grunting)
(baby screaming)
(coughs)
- Jason!
(foreign language)
Jason!
Where's Jason, where is he?
(foreign language)
Where is he?
- Sully, help me!
Help me, help me!
- [Sully] Just jump, Jason! Jump!
- Help me man, help me!
- Jump!
- I can't--
- Break it!
Fuckin' break it!
- I can't break it!
(dramatic music)
- What's the split?
- 50-50, us and the supplier.
(bag unzips)
- Here.
- Good.
(bag zipping up)
(hip hop music)
- Let's get the fuck outta here.
(rap music)
- Why don't you come over and visit us?
- What, you and Paul?
- Yes, me and Paul, and your daughter.
- Sophie opened the door and there
was a big furry, stripy tiger.
And the tiger said argh!
- You scared me!
- (chuckles) The tiger said,
- "Excuse me, but I'm very hungry.
"You think I could have tea with you?"
- Sophie's mommy said
"Of course, come in".
Sorry.
Do your thing.
(gunshots)
(car tires squealing)
(gun shots)
(engine revving)
(glass shattering)
(Sully panting)
(bang & glass shattering)
- Oh, fuck!
(gunshots)
- Fuck!
- Who's that?
- Rickey, yo, man!
- Shit!
(glass shattering)
(gunshot)
(thud)
- Sully!
(gunshots)
- Sully, you're fuckin' dead!
- Hey, fuck nigga!
(Shotgun blast)
(pained grunts)
- Yo, Sully, get up, man!
(gun fire)
Yo fam, yo, ay, come on, man!
- (grunts) Come on!
- Get up, man, fuck!
Come on!
(gun fire)
So y'all cool then, yeah?
- Nah, D, yo, Dris.
Yeah, it's happening now.
Ay, not him, fam, let's go!
Yo, let's go, let's do this!
(heavy EDM music)
- Can I put some shoes on?
- Look, come on, bro.
Stop it, come on.
- Can I at least say bye to him?
- No, come on, come--
(door slams)
Shh!
Don't do that to me!
Let's go, come on!
Come on, man.
You know what you done!
(sad violin music)
It's between us.
Why, why man?
- If you're gonna do it, do it, fam.
(single gunshot)
(wind whistling)